how's it going braces and for this
week's prize one pawpaw
oh [ __ ] we are going to read some of
best comments that I get on YouTube now
know what you're thinking what foods
you're trying off to Commons that's how
you sound like by the way just kidding
these are well collected from Twitter or
from old videos alright first comment
PewDiePie
you're a [ __ ] you know alright
you work your corners and I got mine all
right
Jesus why are your headphones pink
Lowell much say Amen good luck for the
future Peter pie I'm not able to watch
your video for more than 10 seconds
buying Kaua'i things well your internet
must be really bad did you buy you suck
and you swallow you spit damage get
cancer [ __ ] your girlfriend looks like
a foot well damn I must have some weird
foot fetish get oh here's again get
cancer you [ __ ] [ __ ] you look like
a tree
[Music]
that's awesome thank you PewDiePie you
[ __ ] a little piece of gay [ __ ] some
[ __ ]
and gay is that is that a double
negative does that make me straight I'm
so confused
Nikita if you wanted if you want to date
me all we have to do is ask
PewDiePie does suck his fans are the
most stupid and ignorant people
he can't even pronounce his name
properly with the way he spells it his
name should pronounce pewdiepie not
pewdiepie you don't pronounce die die
you got me you got me good you know what
I don't want to talk about him anymore
I'm not replying to any of these stupid
comments and then someone Reyes wrote I
agree dude by the way Peter pie is
cancer to YouTube thanks mate I didn't
think I would get any supporters I
thought it would get haters I appreciate
your response and then a replies back
thanks buddy how I face I shipped them
so much I like the yogscast
[Music]
you're a dick
actually it's your it's my only pair of
sunglasses it's pretty fun so far
god Felix just stop making jokes about
the Illuminati it's not even funny if
everyone would know the truth no one
would even laugh about it you're right
it's very irresponsible of me to joke
about the Illuminati but wait did you
see that I'm sorry
you're H hi my name is Rafael good try
Rafael good try
that's pace gaming team depicting it
says low audio you know how [ __ ] dare
you
yeah you know you put the volume up it's
great try it I don't think you should do
it out of my video zone Kimmy King says
Peter pie is a master raper this is my
first PewDiePie video and I have to say
30 million people must have really
boring lives if they have to watch this
guy or entertainment well this is my
first miss ET comment and I have to say
that she must have really boring life's
to comment on this video if she wasn't
entertainment [ __ ] you [ __ ] you may say
how about that I'm kidding P divides the
worst youtuber ever he just plain sucks
just kidding I only do this for
attention because my channel has no view
source of Scott dammit PewDiePie is a cc
[ __ ] but Ted's PDA is so [ __ ] gay
it hurts
[Music]
that must be from all the gay sex we had
be right back
be here at be right back be right back
beauty pie I gotta do my chores I'll you
know what I'll wait
I'm back oh great welcome back next one
is a video summary with you - does
everyone love pewdiepie i hate PD boy he
rented me his hair looks like a go a
where I first saw him I gagged
he has head life he's weird
and it all it does is just say oh look
at me I've got the first describers in
the world oh wow
well guess what that's the work part of
you team you what are you gonna do it's
in our water
[Music]
I said I'm out I can't do this anymore
all right
wasn't that great yeah I get a lot of
weird [ __ ] tweet it to me or accomodate
to me or whatever the [ __ ] but the good
part about it is that it's even though
there are the shitty comments they are
literally drowned by all the awesome and
amazing ones that I get from you bros I
just want to say I really appreciate
that and I hate to make it seem like I
want more nice comments to feed my ego
because my ego can never have enough
feeding but it's always really cool to
have you bro ser to contrast all the
[ __ ] alright other than that everybody
enjoyed this episode if you did leave a
like cuz otherwise I get so sad Hitler
to spit at zebras the next one because
the brofist for you stay awesome
[Music]